[Applaudissements]
koné seydou ba oui vous l'aimez bien
humainement je sais pas mais j'aime
passer
soit honnête moi je n'aime pas
pourquoi tu voulais pas la détestation
[Musique]
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose à dire à jean bessière
soit trois minutes
[Rires]
je reste
maire séjour
y avait le jugement moubarak est il vrai
que vous avez je m'en bats les quais en
jeu réussie est ce que vous êtes content
de revenir voir booba ce qu il a accepté
de revenir que vous veniez c'est sympa
mais pas accepter jésus
je vais pas tarder alors est-ce que vous
avez été vexé l'homme à la fois jeté un
peu vexé et enfin j'ai pas compris
pourquoi on pouvait pas débattre normal
des mois un débat entre hommes il avance
tout de suite parce que vous avez vous
signé j'ai les miennes marre d'avoir les
dans un pays civilisé auriez envie de
dire à bout bassin voulais mais j'ai
déjà une peu de questions à lui poser
pourquoi avait maintenant je ne discute
pas avec vous mais pourquoi et
voilà vous dis voilà vous que vous lisez
ce que qu elle ressentit vous avez là
vers fois parce que chez vous avez été
un petit peu vexé mais le ressenti c'est
quelqu'un qui veut pas discuter qui a
peut-être peur de dix ans vous avez 2 c
à l'écouter on va parler de moi vous
avez des choses à dire dit oui oui mais
je peux dire globalement des chaussures
là mais bon ma position sur la paix est
déjà connu mais ça n'aura sanaryenne
j'ai rien contre vous personnellement
voyez mais d'état mais voilà je
m'interroge simplement pourquoi
quelqu'un qui est aussi talentueux que
vous parce que je vous reconnais quand
même un talent vous êtes mieux suivis
par des millions de personnes et les
millions de disques pourquoi vous pouvez
pas utiliser votre talent plus
positivement avec des paroles qui sont
plus constructive qui peuvent alimenter
positivement notre jeunesse moi je vous
dis à mes enfants d'écrire mes textes
mais les enfants musique vous tue alors
vous savez c'est à mes textes avec vous
en vous entendre je veux des droits
d'auteur je vais te tutoie laissez-moi
fatigué
alors là et je pense que peuvent
énormément de personnes n'ont pas
compris pourquoi eux booba avait refusé
le débat et la fois y compris des gens
qui l'aiment et les gens vous avez été
extrêmement durs et booba enfin vous
êtes arrivé vous avez dénigrer sa
musique sans appel lui dire bonjour à ce
que vous pouvez reconnaître vous était
quand même très dur avec lui mais
j'aimerais j'ai pas dénigrer g si on
était là pour débattre donc moi j'étais
là pour donner un avis et vous lui
rentrer dedans pour faire face
directement rien du tout j'ai citées ces
textes là il va rien dire à ses côtés
j'ai cité c'était par exemple la
dernière fois il m'a quand j'ai voulu
lui parler il m'a dit je parle pas et
est ce que tu es raciste bon j'ai sur
ben c'est pas d'abord c'est pas vrai un
débat moi j'étais raciste des millions
de personnes jusqu'à moi donc à des
millions de personnes racistes mon
impression là là là là on sera heureuse
de le dollar c'est ce qu'ils dégagent de
toi de tes tweet d'accord et quand avec
la merde mais quand tu écris ou et bon
maghreb où sont mes negro c'est pas
raciste non
c'est la négrophobie c'est du racisme
comme sont les niveaux vous diriez
negron vous derrière toi
voilà donc n'a qu'une n'accusez pas les
gens alors que vous même vous avez des
textes et je parle même pas du cpar du
sexisme aujourd'hui j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure j'ai ramé - elle s'est justifiée
moi je m'exprime par rapport à
l'histoire par rapport à l' esclavage la
guerre d'algérie des choses qui se sont
passées des toits c'est pas jules
s'exprime beaucoup rapport à l'esclavagé
ou bas
si non mais écoutez ses textes enfin il
faut quand même pas je sais pas danser
tech ça saute pas aux yeux qu à domicile
est folle et
c'est des textes qui sont quand même
assez circonstancié nom assez violent
assez violent et qui dégage une forme
une forme de haine même si la musique
peut être très belle par ailleurs mais
c'est quoi le débat qui dénonce beaucoup
de choses il a même pas débat il voulait
vous la voulez vous voulez voir voilà
comme ça juste mémoire tchèque
[Applaudissements]
j'étais son cousin tu veux faire assez
féerique non tu veux c'est pour faire
plaisir aux riffs ou aller pourquoi
la se concentrer
je suis pas en état de choc alors encore
un j'ai une question pour jean vous avez
des enfants qui écoutent du rap gris
quand ils ont pris cette séquence avec
booba j'ai été déçu pourquoi de vous non
mais ça noir d'hobart s'est engraissé
a clairement échoué bah non non je
m'étais mis
derrière mes enfants sont pas ma
propriété ils aiment ce qu'ils veulent
et puis partir une main devant une main
derrière s'est passé en fait le
déshonneur n'a pas été bien il a été
celui qui a refusé de débattre c'est
bien que ce soit vous ayez discuter
quand même je pense à main c'est
toujours moi moi je suis toujours avancé
lancé la série sur moi combien de
griffes il a été faire plus voilà
combien de fois vous m'avez invité sur
votre place ou y compris dans des
plateaux très social les corps étrangers
refusé sur jamais non voilà donc là
c'est bien parce que je voulais vous
parliez ce soir parce qu'il a il avait
été vexé voilà donc commencer je sors
ouais ouais non voilà c'est pour ça
qu'il était un blessure narcissique
ouais c'est ça
un jour mais c'est bien
depuis j'ai dormi a obligé de dormir